The key to maintaining the virtual memory abstraction is
a layer of indirection. Without this layer of indirection, two
processes couldn't use the same address for a variable,
because then they would end up overwriting each other. This
would make life very difficult for programmers and compilers.
So, we play one of the classic computer science tricks
and introduce a layer of indirection. Inside the operating
system, each process has something called the page table that
acts like a phone directory or a dictionary. Giving for
each virtual address, the physical address that it corresponds to.
Usually this will be a place in memory, but when
space in main memory is low it might also be on
part of the disk, called swap in many systems. And
when a program is first starting up, you usually don't
load the whole application into memory first thing but rather
leave part of the program, that might not always be needed,
on the disk. This indirection allows us to accomplish
several things. First, it allows us to have an address
space that is bigger than physical main memory. This is
convenient when main memory itself isn't big enough and we
need to use the disk, or when we want
to map other storage devices and treat them like memory.
Second, it provides protection between processes, as mentioned earlier, without
indirection the applications might find
themselves overwriting each other's data.
With the operating system properly managing the page tables,
however, these two virtual addresses can be pointed to different
physical addresses. Thirdly, it can allow for sharing. Even
different virtual addresses can be made to refer to the
same physical address, again, just by properly maintaining the
page tables. Lastly I should point out that because kernel
addresses are the same for each process, they get
their own page table that is shared among the processes.
This is called the global page table.